[Music]
i'm keith olbermann in this is the
resistance there are for the first time
Inklings that some republican leaders
realize the magnitude of the crime they
may be abetting after the fact are aware
of the political suicide that supporting
him will have become no later than this
time next year and are prepared to help
prevent this country from having to tear
itself apart over donald trump's
collusion with russia and his inevitable
removal from office prepared to help if
we can help them find what is so glibly
called a climb down polling shows one in
eight trump voters are having second
thoughts polling shows the surge
counties Trump won by thirty six points
his net approval there is now just 16
points polling shows the flip counties
Trump won by eight points his approval
is gone there his net disapproval is now
seven points there the result of that
Trump might have actually been bordering
on reality when he tweeted this Sunday
afternoon it's very sad that Republicans
even some that were carried over the
line on my back do very little to
protect their president those
Republicans in both houses were ready to
pass legislation preventing Trump from
lifting sanctions against Russia for
election interference that only he still
publicly contends they did not do they
all but dared him to veto it Richard
burr the Republican who heads the Senate
Intelligence Committee conducted a
closed-door meeting with Obama's
National Security Advisor Susan Rice
Trump wanted the Republican who headed
the House Intelligence Committee Devin
newness to conduct a virtual public show
trial about rice and the unmasking of
Americans caught up in the surveillance
of foreign agents burr not only said he
did not ask Susan Rice about unmasking
but he added on the record quote the
unmasking thing was all created by Devon
newness Republican congressman McCaul of
Texas said of trumps stress against the
special counsel if he fired Bob Muller I
think he'd see a tremendous backlash
from both Democrats but also from House
Republicans Republican Senator Collins
of Maine said he should not say anything
about the special counsel his staff or
the investigation I know it's hard but
he needs to step back and not comment
Republican congressman Jones of North
Carolina recoiled at Trump bashing the
Attorney General I am very disappointed
that the president would make that kind
of statement about a man who I don't
agree with on everything Republican
congressman Simpson of Idaho said at
first it was well yeah this is the guy
we elected he'll learn he'll learn and
you just don't see that happening
Republican congressman Womack of
Arkansas said were just in some
quicksand right now Republican senator
corker of Tennessee said things are
starting to feel incoherent these
statements are on the record from
Republican members in both houses about
a Republican president a Republican
president who's already declared he is
running for a second term who's already
started his campaign who's only in
office six months and he is hanging on
by his fingernails good grief what are
the Republicans saying about Donald
Trump off the record well after Trump
trashed his fatally compromised Attorney
General and longtime loyalists Jeff
Sessions the unnamed sources poured out
of the White House it's chilling one
told CNN quote no one was more loyal
than sessions
no one said another one Republican
senator anonymously said the Attorney
General is America's top law enforcement
official it's unclear if he Trump
understands that and that's pretty
disturbing another Republican senator
was quoted as saying one gets the
impression that Trump doesn't understand
or he willfully disregards the fact that
the Attorney General and law enforcement
in general they are not his personal
lawyers to defend and protect him
another Republican senator was just as
disturbed by Trump's threats against
Muller any thought of firing the special
counsel is chilling and any attempt to
shut down the Justice Department probe
would force Congress to launch its own
special investigation a vaguely
identified top Republican suggested if
it could happen two sessions it could
happen to anyone an unnamed Republican
representative said to the New York
Times it's like having a t-rex wandering
around one day he's been
justic the next day he's eating you and
perhaps most damaging to trump and most
hopeful to those of us who would like to
see this metaphorical political hostage
drama and with Trump giving himself up
or at least being dragged out by his own
party Trump appears to have tried to
scare other senators and failed at a
White House meeting Trump called to try
to reanimate repeal he issued a veiled
threat to their jobs evidently not
realizing or ignoring that 22 of the
Republican senators were elected last
November to terms that last two years
longer than his own after the Republican
senator Moran of Kansas publicly bailed
out on repeal and replaced without even
telling the White House first the former
executive director of the National
Republican Senatorial Committee robbed
Jess Merced right now nobody's afraid of
Trump and that's a real problem and an
unnamed senator was even more brutal
quoting the New York Times the president
he said scares no one in the Senate not
even the pages it is to be remembered
that Richard Nixon was not forced out of
office by the Democrats the Democrats
controlled both the House and the Senate
every day Nixon was in office it was
only in the summer of 1974 when key
Republicans like senator Barry Goldwater
and Senate Minority Leader Hugh Scott
and House Minority Leader John Rhodes
did the math and saw a Republican
bloodbath in the upcoming midterms that
they went to Nixon and forced him out
the attack on sessions the threat
against Muller the browbeating of
senators who have more job security than
he does are all signs of a trump
spiraling out of control but the
Republican responses especially the
Russian sanctions bill and the blowback
against and about sessions combined with
the slowly leaking support from those
who voted for this monster suggests
again that they are all beginning to
look for a way out a climb down because
the analogy of Trump's presidency to a
Tyrannis
Saurus Rex is apt not the part about the
arms or the hands but when the real heat
arrived t-rex not only suffered
extinction but when the heat came it
came so damn quickly he probably never
knew what hit him
moreover anybody depending on t-rex for
protection perished by his side resist
remove peace